>>> The federal trade commission and 17 states
launching a lawsuit against Amazon.
The suit accuses Amazon of having a uponopoly
over the retail environment and using market
size and power to raise prices for consumers.
>> People are paying higher prices.
Consumers are paying more, small businesses
are having to pay 50% Amazon tax right now,
and so ultimately the complaint is seeking
to restore the lost promise of competition,
greater competition means lower prices, better
quality, better selection, and greater innovation.
And that's ultimately what this case is about.
>> The case allegations unfairly promotes
its own platforms and services harming third-party
sellers who rely on Amazon to sell their goods.
The claim has followed Amazon for years.
[7:57:28 AM]
for years.
Lena khan wrote about this in 2017 as a lieu
student.
Here is how she explained it to us in 2019.
>> A situation when a single company is able
to set the terms of the marketplace.
That's a situation where we should worry about
the market not being competitive.
>> That year I asked the then-ceo of Amazon
worldwide consumer Jeff Welke about these
criticisms.
Amazon's marketplace dominance.
Here's what he said.
>> Does Amazon give priority to unprioritize
its private label in search?
>> We prioritize the things that customers
want.
>> A recent hearing on capitol hill an Amazon
attorney went a step further and categorically
denied the claim.
>> We don't use their individual data when
making decisions to launch private brand.
Our incentive is to help the seller to succeed
because we rely on them.
>> When Wilkie left the company in 2021, Lina
khan told CNN the
[7:58:30 AM]
in 2021, Lina khan told CNN the ftc has not
ruled out holding Amazon executives personally
lived for the company's alleged conduct if
they find sufficient evidence.
Mazon says it could cause the very problems
is hopes to solves and, quote, if the ftc
gets its way, the result would be fewer products
to choose from, higher prices, slower Dallas
and reduce options for small businesses.
This is not the ftc's only lawsuit against
Amazon.
It's suing several executives alleging schemes
to enroll people into their prime memberships
without knowing.
You have been focused on this all morning.
>> Did I email you enough about it?
>> I love those emails.
I learn a lot from them.
What is your take?
Because 14 a huge moment not just for the
ftc, the Biden administration, and Lina khan.
>> This has been her fight.
She is the first who raised the question to
this country about what a monopoly, do we
have to change the way we define a monopoly
from the Microsoft days
[7:59:32 AM]
monopoly from the Microsoft days to what Amazon
is now.
My question is, it's important to track 17
states attorney general are onboard.
What does it mean for people at home and who
sell on Amazon.
If they prevail, is it just going to be fines
and penalties or will actual changes happen
that benefit them?
Amazon, too, saying if you succeed in what
you are trying to do, it's just going to cost
people more.
It's groundbreaking.
See where it goes.